you know you hear these stories
obviously of these Child Actors and they
just [__] go to hell they just become
alcoholics and drug addicts and
rightfully so they don't have any sort
of understanding about the real world
they're in this like bubble and all of a
sudden they're just pushed you know the
Biebers of the world and the uh what's
his name I just read his uh just a geek
Will Wheaton Will Wheaton talks about
like he never even wanted to do it but
his mom sort of made him do it and you
know he had his falling out and sort of
like you know now he doesn't talk to his
parents at all I cut them off completely
which is the hardest thing he's ever had
to do and he was on the podcast we
talked about that and um
when did you hit that spot did you ever
hit that spot or were you always like
hey I'm lucky I I had a good head on my
shoulders I didn't Veer too much that
way
well I just I think that I just never
like that successful what do you mean no
like I feel like things were pretty good
but it was never like you never were
superstars with yourself well I feel
like there was just never this like line
of people like waiting to like high-five
me and tell me I'd made it like by the
time I sort of had any awareness that
like things were going pretty good I was
already that that was already
in a way in the rear view like that the
that ship had already kind of sailed and
I felt like I was going into catch-up
mode really yeah and you're saying like
she's all that when that whole thing
yeah like when when you're it was very
strange when people were like oh my gosh
you're in a movie that's in the theater
so it's the number one this weekend
exactly and it made all this money and
people are excited because it made money
you just it it feels like an accident
and then you're kind of like I I mean it
took me probably
I don't know two three years to be like
oh that was kind of neat and then I
didn't book anything that was totally
awesome until Josie and the Pussycats
after that because I was just like
trying to be cool and live in indyville
and do like fun Indie movies and like I
don't know have that kind of like
so-called credibility because that scene
was so vibrant at the time you remember
you were there oh yeah so um so yeah by
that point
and then I made Josie which didn't make
any box office money and then when
people think that you don't make dollars
and cents you're in trouble
isn't it and that becomes a big cult
movie and people tons of fans come out
of the word work later yeah 20 quick
years later here we are I mean it's a it
is it became before that oh totally
totally but it's uh but it's scary to be
attached to a dollar value you know what
I mean it's like it worked for me I've
never been attached to a dollar value no
but like but you are in the sense that
like you can like those movies that your
agent you know calls you about that are
like hey Michael we got an offer it's
XYZ you know 100K for you to go to
Bulgaria Saskatchewan yeah or
Saskatchewan for for
um they can shoot you out no no they can
show you out in two weeks and then
there's some people who you have never
heard of but who have a lot of credits
in Croatia in the rest of the movie and
you're just like oh okay like this is
what this movie is worth overseas like
that's like that's what those those
paychecks and those movies